[Musique]
face à la première
voilà bonjour bonjour à vous tous
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition de
face à la première
notre invité aujourd'hui et fred michel
terrot bonjour bonjour monsieur ko gyan
ou aux auditeurs de martinique 1ère
merci d'être présent dans ce studio de
martinique que première en radio et
internet
fred michel terrot vous êtes le maire de
la ville de saint-esprit
et puis également président des
républicains de martinique
il est exact voilà nous allons évoquer
d'abord là votre actualité de mer et
puis en deuxième partie d'émission
nous allons également nous mettre dans
la perspective de la prochaine élection
du président ou de la présidente des
républicains en france et comment se
passe cette campagne interne au parti
ici en martinique mais si vous voulez
bien nous commençons par le congrès des
maires de france c'était le 100e
c'était il ya quelques jours et donc ce
n'était pas ça a commencé non pas lundi
de cette semaine mais lundi de la
semaine dernière 10 20 novembre merci
pour la précision de la date
nous allons y revenir parce que
traditionnellement ce congrès des maires
de france commence par une journée
consacrée aux outre-mer mais plus
globalement ce congrès a été cette année
une sorte de grand bureau des plaintes
en tout cas c'est l'impression que
beaucoup en ont eu de la part des maires
dans un contexte il est vrai on ne peut
pas le nier difficile un notamment de
contraintes budgétaires
et puis avec donc la question des angles
de la suppression des emplois aidés qui
avait un peu plombé l'ambiance et puis
la perspective de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation présenter tout cela
j'en viens à ma question fred michel
terrot présenté par le président de la
république et sa majorité par un effort
nécessaire que doivent faire aussi les
collectivités locales dont les
municipalités pour réduire la dette de
l'état le déficit public alors c'est
vrai que la perception qu'on a de
l'extérieur de ce congrès est parfois
complètement différent de la réalité
c'est le cas encore aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'en écoutant la presse on regarde
la télévision on avait l'impression
qu'il y avait une rivalité entre deux
coûté la présidence de la république et
les maires qui étaient venus en découdre
pas du tout ce centième du congrès des
maires étaient un peu sifflé on va pas
résumer le congrès des maires une
intervention du président la république
le congrès terre mais est elle une
semaine ou plus de trente mille
personnes étaient présentes où il ya eu
plus de 150 formations
c'est souvent ça le congrès des maires
c'est toujours ça d'ailleurs d'abord une
forme d'information des ateliers traves
de travail et formation des débats des
ateliers de travail avec les maires les
conseillers municipaux les agents
municipaux aussi parce que souvent nous
avons des agents municipaux qui
participent au congrès des maires et ce
100ème congrès des maires c'était
d'abord l'occasion pour les élus de se
retrouver de se former d'apprendre ce
qui avait eu comme nouveauté vous savez
qu'on a transféré la compétence par
exemple des pacs la rédaction des pacs
ou mairie depuis le 1er novembre 2010
est donc c'est l'occasion aussi de se
former mais je vous remets à toutes
sortes de d'actualité la petite enfance
les finances et puis aussi l'actualité
plus récente des contrats aidés mais
c'est d'abord ça le congrès des maires
c'est aussi bien évidemment des
discussions des camps discours le
discours du premier ministre qui est
venu aussi ça lui les maires le discours
du président de la république qui est
venu le jeudi en fin de congrès mais le
progrès des mères c'est aussi le salon
ont des moeurs c'est à dire des
exposants des centaines d'exposants qui
présente aux différentes municipalités
présente mais ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer le cadre de vie d'une commune
vous allez trouver des véhicules vous
allez trouver des réverbères solaire
vous allez trouver des prêts bancaires
vous allez trouver des méthodes tout
fait pour monter une crèche y en
quelques années
voyez tous ceux d'autres mais où des
élus peuvent avoir besoin à nous faire
avancer la ville d'accord donc c'est
vrai des mères c'est d'abord ça d'abord
ça d'abord saluons les six breaks des
changes dessus d'arrêter de boîte à
outils
the hobbit et c'est d'abord ça et ça
revêtait c'est vrai une importance
particulière cette année non pas parce
que c'est le centième parce que mon
bateau centièmes mais aussi parce que
c'était la première fois que le
président de la république nouvellement
élu monsieur mâcon vient d'être est
présente et syndicaux et aussi donner
des précisions ce contexte que j'ai
indiquées comme tout à fait beaucoup
parler quand même notamment sur les
réductions de dotation oui la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
parce que tous les administrés sont
contents en entendant le président a
annoncé une suppression de la taxe
d'habitation pour moins 80% des ménages
parce que c'est à juste dit on il faut
c'est faut supprimer ce cadeau sympa où
s'ébattent à terme ce sens at il dit sur
le principe vous vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas contre après il faut savoir que
l'état c'est nous aussi un écho la taxe
d'habitation c'est pas par plaisir qu'on
vous confient des taxes c'est que la
collectivité communale elle a besoin de
cette taxe pour fonctionner pour rendre
des services aux administrés pour
construire des routes pour nettoyer les
quartiers pour aménager les écoles pour
open des dispensaires pour construire
des piscines pour innover des terrains
de basket pour vous ce sont surtout des
recettes avons veillé les agents mais
s'est déroulé en moins ça veut dire que
nous avons moins de pouvoir d'achat pour
beaucoup de huy du pouvoir d'achat mais
ça veut dire qu'il ya moins de service
qui sera rendu par les municipalités
vous croyez pas à la promesse des
manuels un coup ça va être compensée
c'est parce que j'aime bien les gars
c'est parce que j'ai déjà dit que ça
avait légitimement quelques inquiétudes
parce que souvent on nous annonce une
une compensation régulièrement on a
cette compensation la première année
puis la deuxième année on n'a pas la
compensation qu'on avait l'année
précédente
parce que si l'état veut réduire ses
déficits forcément il va le faire
position quelqu'un quand il nous dit je
supprime la taxe d'habitation il faudra
bien qu'ils trouvent l'argent ailleurs
il fonctionnait avec une certaine somme
quand il supprime la taxe d'habitation
et va le récupérer d'une autre main donc
c'est un peu
facile de dire nous allons faire
disparaître la taxe d'habitation cette
année fédéral aussi surtout c'est une
promesse c'est une mauvaise on est de
toute manière ce qui donnait de la main
droite sera récupérée de la main gauche
puisque nous avons des frais
incompressibles
sauf à dire que et a expliqué aux
administrés que bien on va moins se
curer les rivières on va moins se
nettoyer les routes on va repeindre
moins que les écoles et on ne pourra pas
climatisé toutes les salles de classe
aux écoles où il fait chaud en
martinique par exemple voyez donc il
faut bien faire comprendre que cette
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
risque d'avoir des conséquences très
importantes sur les communes qui sont en
première ligne
les décisions sont prises par exemple
votre bonne ville de saint esprit la
taxe d'habitation vous avez déjà prêt
mesurer cent mille euros en moins à peu
près voilà huit cent mille euros par
années c'est énorme
alors quand on nous dit on va compenser
à l'euro près vous demandez un espère on
espère la tendre je ne suis pas ce petit
que j'attends je suis patient ce qui
veut dire qu'il faudra effectivement
être patients parce que ce qu'il a
annoncé le président la république n'est
pas tellement différent de ceux qui la
vanne a annoncé avant c'est à dire que
ce congrès des maires n'a pas été pour
nous les maires et et conseils
municipaux une nouveauté ya pas eu d
annonce surprenante
on a trouvé un président la république
assez ferme sur ses propos assez assez
détaché de ce que les maires pouvaient
porter comme inquiétudes et il a indiqué
écouté mon goût vous avez beau me
sifflent et vous avez vous revendiquez
moi j'ai pris ma décision et je vais me
tenir donc
la loi est faite en eau et puis nous
nous sommes hull comme on dit souvent
les mères les fantassins de la
république nous allons assumer mais il
faut quand même que ce prix dans la
république soit quand même peu plus à
l'écouté des trains de 6000 maires de
france puisque c'est nous qui
connaissons le mieux je crois les
aspirations de nos populations et qui
sommes au contact de nos administrés
alors le congrès des maires aussi c'est
l'occasion pour les maires de martinique
et de du saint-esprit aussi donc
alors que diront des dégâts témoin vous
étiez en oui on n'est pas votre
présentation
parfois la réalité bien c'est pour cet
honneur et u17 dos 3-3 élus dans
l'hérault et dépenses étaient prises en
charge par la ville mais quatre qui sont
elles aussi par leurs propres moyens
parce que c'est aussi l'occasion pour
nous de nous former donc on va souvent
assez nombreux parce que même avec nos
propres moyens parce que c'est aussi une
formidable opportunité pour les élus de
se former et puis de rencontrer les
spiritains de l'hexagone puisque nous
faisons une réunion tous les ans avec
les spiritains qui vivent dans
l'hexagone
ça a été le cas pour nous le samedi 18
novembre et nous avons rencontré une
centaine de spiritains qui se sont
déplacés avec qui en a pu échanger et
puis montre un peu l'évolution de la
ville aux cours d'été de l'année écoulée
alors traditionnellement le congrès des
maires de france
la première journée est consacrée aux
outre mer c'est la journée de
l'outre-mer voilà et ça a encore été le
cas pour cette édition 2010 est pour ce
100ème congrès avec notamment
l'intervention parmi d'autres de
nourrice bonté le président de
l'association des maires de la
martinique
vous avez participé à sept
jeunesse première du lundi 20 novembre
oui cette journée se déroule au siège de
l'association des maires de france en
plein paris au quai d'orsay d'ailleurs
alors c'est une réunion entre élus
ultramarins c'est une raison encore élus
ultramarins donc tous les représentants
des élus de l'outre-mer sont présents
donc wallis et futuna la polynésie la
réunion la martinique la guadeloupe la
guyane saint-pierre-et-miquelon
le ministre de l'outre-mer assistent à
cette réunion et bien évidemment le
président de l'association des maires
françois bach en exil et s est
l'occasion pour chaque président
d'association des mers d'exposer un peu
la situation de son département de son
territoire en tout cas et puis de de
faire des suggestions
les propositions et même des demandes
puisque le ministre de l'outre-mer et
prison mais c'est aussi l'occasion de se
retrouver après entre midi et deux avec
le ministre de l'outre-mer qui a partagé
quelques échanges avec nous pendant deux
bonnes heures
donc c'est l'occasion aussi de se
rencontrer et d'échanger très librement
parce qu'on a un ministre de l'outre-mer
qui est assez directe qui ne n'a pas de
fils qu'il n'y a pas de formalisme et
les assez direct à madame annick
girardin juin lors d'un de ses clients
elle est un peu comme son territoire et
me le dit woods un peu comme son
territoire et on a échangé très
librement j'ai pu discuter avec elle je
suis les sujets alors juste j'avais
retenu de particuliers de
à vos yeux qu'est ce qui ressortit alors
ces échangeurs chose donc j'ai profité
pour faire passer certains messages pour
notre territoire de la martinique donc
d'expliquer d'exposer parce que c'est un
ministre qui 13 à écoute moi j'ai trouvé
donc elle viendra d'ailleurs en
martinique et m'annoncer qu'elle viendra
en martinique
du 15 au 19 décembre elle arrive le
vendredi 15 au soir
dès le samedi merci de le soutenir si
cela donc je lui demandé de rencontrer
les maires de rencontrer les maires
puisque vous ne vous a pas échappé que
le premier ministre qui est passé en
novembre dernier dans notre île n'a pas
rencontré les maires alors il s'est
arrêté sur la tombe de d'aimé césaire le
premier ministre il n'a pas rencontré
les maires ce qui m'a fait dire que les
morts sont peut-être plus important que
les mères
donc c'est important quand même que nous
que le ministre et les élus les grands
élus qui passent à la martinique en
compte que les élus qui sont premiers en
ouvre par les d'edouard philippe al le
produit on dit oui voilà donc elle
rencontre allumèrent samedi samedi 16
nous pourrons échanger et présenter
aussi nous demander notre vision pour la
martinique
alors j'ai trouvé également ce que j'ai
retenu c'est de constater que nous élus
de l'outre-mer de martinique en
particulier nous étions quand même assez
en retrait de ce genre d'événement et je
trouve que on a peut-être manqué un peu
de lobbying
si vous voulez et j'ai trouvé des
guadeloupéens beaucoup mieux organisés
beaucoup plus présent beaucoup plus en
contact
alors dis donc c'est une tendance
globale malheureusement que je note donc
la notation des efforts mais justement
lobbying auprès des autorités
ministérielles très bien à ce moment de
notre entretien et comme on parle de ce
100ème congrès des maires de france à
laquelle a participé la martinique avec
sa délégation vous l'avez dit de six ou
sept maires non tous pratiquement tous
les maires de la martinique était là
quand j'ai dit si sur cet élu c'est les
élus du saint-esprit revanche 1
la plupart des mères et lé congrès
congrès la quasi totalité des maires de
martinique était au congrès des maires
avec des délégations donc nous étions
plus d'une centaine seulement il y avait
main le mal compris que vous parle
régulièrement nous étions plus elle sans
fil à une début de la martinie toi ce
congrès maurice monter le président de
l'association des maires de martinique
quels sont vos rapports avec lui vos
relations mais sont très bonnes c'est
sont très bonnes ça se passe bien je
suis aussi membre du bureau de
l'association des maires parce que je
suis les cdd un général de l'association
ça se passe très bien nous avons une
association donc dynamique avec un
président qui se réunit régulièrement le
mercredi après-midi et donc les choses
se passent très bien
vous savez sa mère vous un possible
successeur à maurice monter quand il
coupa les passionnés pour ça du tout non
mais rien à dire là qui vous vous cite
parmi les possible prochain président de
l'association des maires de martinique
dont vous savez je n'écoute pas trop ce
qu'on dit ou les rumeurs ou les bruits
moi ce qui m'intéresse d'abord c'est
être le plus efficace possible pour ma
commune
après le reste on verra pour la
martinique d'abord pour ma commune mais
c'est vrai que mais on ne peut pas l
association des maires vous ça va ça
fonctionne bien c'est doris à
fonctionner c'est un outil sur lequel
peuvent réellement s'appuyer les les
quatre maires de l'aude oui d'autant que
contrairement à ce qui se passe dans
d'autres instances l'association des
maires n'est pas du tout politiser voyez
pas y'a pas de kankan des uns contre les
autres et a pas deux pas du tout je vous
assure je vous assure et justement les
médias on
l'important joue à ce niveau doit faire
preuve de pédagogie
je trouve qu'on assiste trop souvent
dans les médias sur ce qui ne va pas sur
les petits kankan et on exacerbe parfois
des difficultés qu'il ya je ne cache pas
un qui a des difficultés parfois à la
ctm mais je vous assure que les maires
quand ils sont dans le quotidien et nous
mais quand on discute entre nous on
regarde pas l'étiquette on oublie même
l'étiquette vous me demandez quelle
étiquette maurice bonté je suis
incapable de vous dire où le maire de
trinité tellement on oublie ses
étiquettes parce qu'on est au quotidien
dans la réalité est vraiment en
déplacement ont sûrement l'élection sur
sa cible en ouvrir d'incidence mais
l'association est terminée une fois
l'élection terminée bon voilà on passe à
autre chose et on travaille avec tout le
monde et dans les conseils municipaux
quelles que soient les tendances quelle
que soit la tendance du maire vous voyez
bien que en général les conseils
municipaux et à jamais un conseil
municipal nous coule color avec 30
conseillers de la même couleur il ya
souvent des gens de toutes tendances
politiques et souvent même avec
l'opposition ça peut se passer très très
bien c'est ça que les amis et justement
et les citoyens attendent de la
politique c'est qu'une fois que le débat
est clos
débat politique c'est à dire une
élection mais qu'il faut se mettre au
travail se rassembler et
c'est ce qu'on attend du politique qui
ne reste pas dans un cancan permanent
comme on le voit parfois dans d'autres
instances
en ce qui concerne la mairie en tout cas
la mairie du saint-esprit et la quasi
totalité des mairies de martinique je
crois il n'y a pas de difficultés les
conseils municipaux travaillent
correctement les travaillent ensemble
dans l'intérêt de leurs efforts les ont
pas juste la musique est aussi avec très
peu de moyens que je rappelle aussi
parce que quand j'entends des coups de
gueule sur votre média d'ailleurs autour
de 19h45 les coûts de façon à l'usé
mondiaux dans le trou mais la france et
ça c'est dommage parce que justement on
aurait dû expliquer que la route de
obligeant parfois c'est une route
départementale
même si elle traverse le bourg de la
commune même si elle traverse la
campagne
c'est une route départementale et ne
relève pas de la compétence du maire et
ça souvent on n'a pas se retourna et
donc ce serait intéressant que les les
médias face aux oeuvres de de
citoyenneté aussi apporté leur pierre à
l'édifice parce que les élus se donnent
beaucoup les élus on oublie ne sont pas
payés les conseils municipaux agissent
bénévolement souvent que je discute avec
les admis ce qu'est cet esprit ou
d'ailleurs ils me disent mes roues mais
je pense que conseiller doit être payée
entre 2 et 3000 e ou pas du tout ces
municipales et payer 0 euros par mois
zéro euro il n'y a que les modalités
précises comme ça mais des actes ou
encore les adjoints oui vous parler du
cancer et municipaux ses missions
oui on est d'accord voilà qui a une
éternité enfin sur la population et ça
c'est important parce que l'élu
notamment l'élu municipal est avant tout
un bénévole donc le fait de tirer comme
ça sur les élus de montrer trop souvent
les cancans alors qu'il ya de bonnes
choses qui se font
eh bien ça décourage le citoyen de venir
travailler dans la politique est
d'apporter sa pierre à l'édifice pour
terminer cette séquence consacrée donc à
la
à la réunion il ya quelques jours deux
des maires de france il ya eu 7 ce
discours dans des manuels accroc on y
revient vraiment pour pour conclure avec
des points donc il a réaffirmé vous le
disiez son engagement ferme cette de
mettre en oeuvre cette promesse
électorale de suppression progressive
sur trois ans de la taxe d'habitation
pour 80% mais ce sera probablement à
terme pour cent pour cent des des
ménages français selon lui c'est un polo
calais a juste et vise notamment des
territoires les plus modestes la classe
moyenne etc
mais il a dit que c'est le premier acte
d'une refonte en profondeur de la
fiscalité que d'une refonte qu'il
souhaite un en profondeur de la
fiscalité locale et notamment communale
dès 2020 oui oui je vois que c'est
nécessaire voilà ce que je voulais avoir
la vision nécessaire parce que
habituellement mais un parti totalement
de deux barèmes tel tellement de choses
compliquées qui date des années 60 70
effectivement il faut refondre puisque
quand vous habitez dans une grande ville
avec l'effet d'échelle dans une grande
ville vous paie une taxe d'habitation
qui est très basse en général
et puis quand vous habitez d'un dans les
villes un peu plus avec moins de
population ou même dans les villages de
france
ben on se rend compte que la taxe
d'habitation et parfois élevés ben oui
puisque parce qu avec peu d'habitants il
faut quand même rendre les mêmes
services
donc quand vous êtes 50 à cotiser parce
que aussi là aussi d'un se rend compte
que dans beaucoup de villes notamment
martinez qui a que 27 % des amis strict
qui paie la taxe d'habitation et que
beaucoup y échappent
ouais on a deux trois appartements qu'on
loue en bas et puis on oublie de
déclarer ça aussi il faut le dire donc
quand on est peu à payer effectivement
le montant de la taxe importants tandis
que quand on est dans des grandes villes
donc il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
rentrées fiscales et un peu
on peut avec une taxe moindre faire
beaucoup plus de choses
voilà mais le congrès nous a aussi
permis de voir et de nous confronter
avec des villes de l'hexagone
finalement de voir que on n'est pas si
mal loti parfois en martinique que
certains certains villages où certaines
villes de 3000 4000 habitants au fin
fond de la creuse ou de la corrèze on a
rencontré des gens dans les alpes qui
reste deux mois sans téléphone fixe
parce que les services ne vienne pas lui
parler parce qu'ils habitent à 1800
mètres d'altitude et on les a
complètement oublié la 4g y voit ça à la
télé mais savent pas où ils ont parfois
la cèze le 512k ils sont bien contents
nous permet de pratiquer
on a tous cas au début un peu partout on
a on a
tout d'équipements informatiques qui le
premier de france
un plus de 50% des ménages équipés un
ordinateur on a le haut débit
pratiquement partout même au morne-rouge
même à fond saint denis même d'année les
montagnes vous voyez ça ça n'existe pas
partout
même s'il ya des difficultés chez nous
et ce n'est pas toujours l'équipe à
l'eau juillet dernier ça va à chaque
fois vous savez monsieur cas où il n'y a
pas beaucoup de départements de 380
mille habitants qui peuvent dire qu'ils
ont deux piscines olympiques
en martinique on a une piscine olympique
au carbet une où la menteuse on a une
piscine ou louerait on n'a vu ni piscine
et au fond ce qu'on aura bientôt une cet
esprit voyez donc en taux d'équipement
aussi sportif on n'est pas mal loti dans
d'autres domaines on est mal lotis mais
on se situe quand même pas si mal que ça
ça veut dire que les élus travaillent
que les élus sont à l écoute de la
population si on a souvent tendance à se
dénigrer mais on est quand même parfois
assez content de voir qu'on n'est pas si
mauvais que ça quelques mots sur les
assises de l'outre-mer ça y est c'est
parti la consultation des citoyennes et
des citoyens sur internet
la tenue de deux premiers ateliers ici
ou là mais bon on n'a pas l'impression
que alors c'est vrai qu'on est en
période de fin d'année
bon c'est que les la fête approche a
fait de nouvelles la fête du nouvel an
etc
on est dans la dans notre période de
quantic mais tout de même les assises de
l'outre-mer est-ce que vous souhaitez
vous que
la population les citoyens des citoyens
d'ici s'implique beaucoup davantage et
puis aussi les élus on en a parlé
d'ailleurs au congrès en affirmant qu'
et à ceux qui ont organisé les assises
de l'outre-mer c'est-à-dire directement
le ministère de l'outre-mer qu'ils
avaient un peu zappé les élus locaux
on nous avait un peu mis de côté oui
mais pourtant c'est important de se
poser la question est ce que c'est je
chante et je sais de rescision wilfred
miss atyrau annick girardin avait
précisé que ces assises doivent en
principe décider de la nouvelle
politique publique pour les outre mer
oui c'est important et c'est important
mais il ya une volonté je vraiment la
part du gouvernement de toucher
directement à la population sans passer
par les élus locaux qui pourrait relier
le message au moins auprès de la
population de participer à ces assises
sauf que c'est une bonne chose mais
après il ya eu les états généraux de
doute cohérent
en 2009 il ya eu il ya aujourd'hui
maintenant les assises donc c'est
toujours bon de consulter la population
pourquoi pas après maintenant à nous de
synthétiser tous les travaux qui vont
sortir de ces assises et puis de mettre
en oeuvre il appartiendra aux politiques
locaux au politique ou parlementaire et
puis aussi à l'état de mettre en oeuvre
les résultats de ces de ces assises donc
on évite effectivement toute la
population à secondes
je crois que c'est fini pour les
expressions sur sur les sites s'étaient
jusqu'au 22 novembre
mais je crois que voilà il y aura livre
bleu outremer qui va sortir et à partir
de bientôt du 15 janvier 2018 donc dans
six semaines à peu près jusqu'au 28
février
le site internet des assises debout
tonnerre de l'outre-mer permettra donc
une vaste consultation numérique de ski
de ce que les ceux qui ont participé ont
voulu faire comme comme proposition
voilà je voulais juste signalé ça parce
que ça fait partie aussi de de
l'actualité de ces jours ci et à venir
aussi le climat politique en martinique
fred michel tir haut
il était déjà attendu avant même
l'élection de décembre 2015
il a continué de l'être dans les mois
qui ont suivi
et jusqu'à maintenant avec ces temps
derniers
des polémiques incessantes autour de la
le non démarrage du tcsp on va plutôt
dire ça comme ça et le conflit qui a
beaucoup cristallisé au parc naturel de
la martinique autour du renvoi on va
dire du directeur de cette de cette
institution quoi de ce syndicat mixte en
fait c'est un syndicat mixte dans lequel
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs figure au conseil
d'administration
toutes les mères est ce que vous êtes
fait partie des signataires jeu avec
jenny dulys l'année mère qui ont signé
ce document
alors c'est vrai qu'il s'est elle va
parler sur le climat ajouté mais il ya
un climat
c'est vrai assez délétère depuis
quelques temps je crois que les deux
parties qui ont dirigé la martinique
depuis 25 ans réalise quelque peu le
bruit comme ça de la barbichette
peut-être parce qu'ils sont proches
idéologiquement finalement parce qu on
oublie que le parti progressiste
martiniquais c'est un parti autonomiste
et nationaliste
si les statuts du ppm qui le disons mais
le parti indépendantiste partie comme
son nom l'indiqué indépendantiste aucun
vocation à amener la population
martiniquaise l'émancipation donc à
l'érection de nation martiniquaise
donc c'est la même chose ne côté la
nation martiniquaise par le mime de côté
un parti autonomiste et nationalistes
par le pp à l'aube c'est pour vous
satisfaire ce pas son pareil mais ils
sont disputés familiale c'est un cousin
ou deux frères qui se vident amant qui
se foutent ils sont sur le même créneau
donc c'est vrai que leurs leaders ont
longtemps tenu le crachoir et on tenait
les rênes l'âme artistique depuis 25 ans
et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est triste
c'est triste à voir et que on attend on
attend notre comportement de la part de
nos élus
et c'est vrai qu'on est parfois dans
l'escaladé verbale et là aussi les
médias c'est vrai on profite et je pense
que c'est vrai que ça fait formidable
passe de résonance je pense que le ver
ne font que non mais qu'est ce que je
vais faire de roi diffusée de diffuser
en direct certaines plénière fait que
certains se donnent en spectacle et
profite pour exacerber pourra pas
l'exclure effectivement je pense que il
ya une partie de ça au départ ça se veut
être de la formation pour les citoyens
les élus nous devons donner l'exemple
nous devons donner l'exemple et une fois
l'élection terminée comme je le disais
tout à l'heure on doit oublier
l'élection et se met au travail et se
met au travail avec toutes les
composantes de l'assemblée qui ont été
élus alors qu'on peut ne pas être dans
le parti politique de celui que l'on a
combattu sur les triture électoraux et
puis après se mettre d'accord pour faire
avancer le tcsp vite mais justement sur
le tcsp
alors ce n'est pas qu'un problème
politique parce que souvent on dit ah le
tcsp n'avance pas ça pour un politique
un tel joueur est toujours en chantier
n'est pas faits s'impose politique il
n'ya pas que ça il ya parfois aussi des
dysfonctionnements administratifs et ça
moi j'ai pu le constater à plusieurs
reprises dans plusieurs collectivités
souvent l'élu et l'administratif
n'arrive pas à prendre leur place
on a souvent des élus qui font le
travail des administratifs et des
administratifs qu'il faut le travail des
élus chacun à sa mission et parfois les
problèmes viennent du fait que les uns
et les autres se marchent sur les pieds
et chez les uns et les autres arrivent
pas à trouver leur place mais chacun à
sa place
les lui là pour prendre des décisions
c'est sa mission prendre des décisions
et l'administratif
son rôle c'est la mise en oeuvre des
décisions et souvent pour les faire
appliquer oui pour pour et
l'administratif doit se caler
à aux politiques surtout quand on est
directeur général des services vous
parlez du parc directeur général des
services
c'est quelqu'un qui s'adapte à son son
président ou à l'exécutif et il a
d'ailleurs cette capacité à s'adapter à
l'exécutif même si l'exécutif change
vous devez vous adapter si vous avez un
exécutif qui est très fort très
dynamique très offensif lors général des
services au sein d'une municipalité au
sein d'une série ou bien sûr c'est un
premier ministre qui s'adapte à son
président
si le président de la république décide
de changer de premier ministre ça ne
veut pas dire qu'ils voient en cause les
compétences ou les qualités techniques
du du premier ministre donc si
l'exécutif souhaite se séparer de son
directeur général des services ça ne
veut pas dire qu il vraiment en cause
ses capacités techniques ou ses
connaissances ou incompétence mais c'est
que le courant ne passe pas et pour que
l'administration fonctionne mais pour
que la collectivité fonctionne bien pour
que le syndicat fonctionne bien pour que
l'état fonctionne bien il faut qu'il y
ait une connivence jallet dit au post
une complicité entre l'exécutif et son
directeur général des services qui est
là pour mettre en application les
décisions qu'il prend non alors souvent
on a cristallisé le fait que deux
personnes se sépara ouais tout de suite
on en a fait un plat non ça arrive
le poste de dgs et un emploi fonctionnel
ça veut dire que on est là pour une
mission bien particulière est là et
souvent donc pour le pnr m pour le parc
justement c'est à terme peut-être mal
compris leur mission deux parties
d'autres je ne jette pas la pierre aux
autres et c'est là où la formation
monsieur cas où j'ai important puisque
aussi bien les élus que les
administratifs doivent se rappeler que
chacun a sa mission
puis on ne peut pas venir faire une
grève parce que l'exécutif décider de se
séparer de son directeur gilles c'est la
loi c'est ça c'est une possibilité qui
est offerte
c'est possible ça ne veut pas dire
encore une fois pour remet en cause la
compétence des uns et des autres ça veut
dire que on ne s'entend pas quelle que
soit la raison alors et donc on peut se
séparer il ya des dispositions qui sont
prévues que l'ensemble on a bien compris
votre analyse de cette situation
particulière mais je n'y a pas bien
dire que c'est possible et aux curieux
se séparer il voue pas se faire sur le
principe
voilà c'est fait l'audi a6 a paralysé
c'est assez logique et ça tombe presque
un peu sous le sens ce que vous dites
mais mais quand même fred messieurs le
tir ou est ce que au delà de ce que vous
venez de dire avec le tcsp aussi mais là
encore plus
est-ce que c'est pas symbolique de ce
climat de de revanche de tensions
exacerbées qu'il ya entre eux
effectivement ces deux partis qui ont
dominé la vie politique de ces vingt
trente dernières années on va un peu
mieux qu'à vous vous en pensez
c'est ce que veut dire eh oui c'est ce
que je vienne limoges a vraiment comment
sortir alors alors ya les élections
c'est aux citoyens de choisir après et
ils sont libres c'est ça moi je dis
souvent aux citoyens mais vous avez
choisi donc vous choisissez puis après
vous suggérer de sortir un peu de ce
cycle d'alternance entre mime et ppm
comme ça où alfred marie-jeanne ensuite
serge letchimy alfred marie jeanne qui
succède à serge letchimy enfin ne dit
mot c'est un peu ce que vous semblez
dire des continents aussi peut-être ici
ou là oui mais on commence à entendre
martine veulent sortir de cette la cmc
dessin 15 mai ses griffes bipartisane
cette vie politique monsieur
l'alternance bipartite il reste encore à
7/7 la possibilité de de faire de grands
pas parce que ça fait ça fait ça fait
seulement deux ans ça fait deux ans oui
quand on a mis enfin 62e et déjà deux
ans si oui déjà 2 à mes potes quand on a
mis en place est 7e et je l'avais dit
dès 2011 au président la république de
l'époque nicolas sarkozy je lui dis
faire une fusion entre guillemets pour
aller vite entre conseil général et un
conseil régional avec deux manières de
fonctionner qui sont différentes de
culture qui sont différentes le conseil
général c'est une vieille maison qu'il
ya plus de 150 ans la région c'est
beaucoup plus jeunes qui avaient à peine
30 ans donc ces deux cultures
différentes
deux maisons différentes faire coexister
de manière de fonctionner différentes
c'est pas évident ça peut prendre du
temps ça peut très bien se passer comme
ça pue ne pas se passer ça une
conséquence sur avait effectivement
cette fusion et puis ce ce manque
d'organigramme qui n'est pas toujours
complet parfois par exemple le tcsp
l'organigramme de martine transport qui
va reprendre le transport non seulement
du tcsp mais également de l'espace sud
de cape nom de tout le transport en
martinique fait d'écarter unique qui
forçaient des syndicats routiers aussi
moi j'attends avec impatience ce que ce
que c'est que cet organigramme soit
finalisé cet organigramme soit finalisée
pour qu'on puisse se met commencer la
gare routière du saint-esprit par
exemple voilà donc pour vous dire que
nous sommes tous dans la tente mais ce
n'est pas qu'un problème politique
encore une fois monsieur k oui je sais
ça peut être aussi a aussi un problème
administratif
parce que c'est aux administratifs aussi
de mettre en place l'année concernant le
tessin mais bien sûr à quatre niveaux
décalage et janola des à la télé son
autorisation
écoutez mais on met toujours tous les
deux des politiques de politique je
voulais dit au début de mon propre os sa
mission principale c'est de prendre des
décisions
la décision de construire tcsp est
terminée après il appartient aux
entreprises chargées de construire le
tcsp et aux administratifs de mettre en
oeuvre la décision qui a été prise
le financement est l'un l'addition est
prise après il appartient à
l'administration de mettre en place la
politique qui est mise en oeuvre donc
c'est trop facile de dire donc là vous
êtes la pondération de dix jeunes ainsi
qu'à celle ci
mais en général je vous dis qu'est en
particulier aussi pour le tcsp
on ne peut pas tout mettre sur le dos ou
le compte des politiques c'est un
problème ya forcément des problèmes
politiques puisque oui mais c'est moi
qui ai réglementation française aussi
quelquefois en la matière jusqu'à ce que
les choses et pas même de régler non
sans problème deux persos ganisation de
l'administration écoutez ce que je vous
dise est un problème est à la fois un
problème politique
oui effectivement des politiques qui se
tirent un peu dans les pattes
donc ça rejaillit aussi sur le
comportement de l'administration qui se
dit si le politique
quand vous êtes l'administration
séguiniste conçoit ses dix agents
monsieur d'accord vous avez oublié qu'à
la région il ya 86 élus mais il ya aussi
4003 sage c'est qu'ils font fonctionner
la machine s'est pas monsieur alfred
marie-jeanne et monsieur claude lise qui
font fonctionner seulement l'un de ses
thèmes
il ya des élus qui prennent des
décisions et il ya des agents qui met en
application les décisions qui sont
prises donc dire le tcsp n'avance pas
c'est à cause d'un homme ou à cause de
quelques élus une poignée d'élus jeudi
c'est un peu facile et un peu un
raccourci c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça il ya à la fois des problèmes
politiques mais à des problèmes
d'organisation des services un problème
d'organisation de l'administration mais
ça ne se voit pas seulement dans les
collectivités se sauvera dans les
hôpitaux aussi monsieur caruge dans les
hôpitaux il ya un problème
d'organisation en général de
l'administration il faudra qu'on se
penche dessus je vois qu'on se penche
sérieusement dessus pour améliorer les
choses donc il appartient évidemment aux
politiques d'impulser de s'entourer des
directeurs généraux des services et des
agents qui sont capables de mettre en
application et met en oeuvre une une
l'organigramme administratif qui soit
capable de faire avancer les choses mais
quand vous avez une administration qui
mal organisés mais ça paralyse les
choses donc avant tout pour qu'une
collectivité fonctionne il faut qu'ils
aient politique clairvoyante et une
vision mais aussi une collectivité bien
organisé par une administration est
notamment directeur général qui peut
organiser les choses au point dès la
rentrée ça j'assiste à une réunion
dernièrement avec une collectivité notre
collectivité
notre collectivité en question que je
veux pas nommer ici à votre micro
n'était pas présente
à cette réunion et poteau c'est une
réunion importante très important il se
trouve que le coup et a pris dix jours
entre le moment où ils étaient à
l'accueil de cette collectivité et au
moment où il arrivait sur le bureau de
l'exécutif
ce n'est pas un problème politique ce
problème d'organisation de
l'administration de cette collectivité
qui peut avoir des conséquences
politiques évidemment mais c'est un
problème administratif
un courrier qui n'arrive pas peut avoir
des conséquences énormes
donc c'est là où je vous dis ce n'est
pas qu'un problème politique c'est aussi
un problème administratif qu'il faut
régler il appartient c'est vrai aux
politiques d'impulser et de bien
s'entourer pour que l'administration
soit fonctionnel en longtemps à
l'entente en quelques mots vous lui
trouvez encore peut-être encore est-ce
que vous lui trouvez tout simplement du
dynamisme du volontarisme à cette
collectivité territoriale de martinique
qui a commencé donc sous l'égide de
comment dirais-je du grand ensemble et
pumba pays en chance donc de ce ce
contrat de gestion dont on rappelle il
ya des membres du parti des républicains
ah oui oui madame ou monsieur mon
plaisir est ce que vous lui trouvez du
dynamisme
par exemple la ctm alfred marie-jeanne
lui-même a sorti un bilan du premier
semestre 2010 est la ctm me dit voilà
580 581 millions neuf cent soixante
quatorze mille et des poussières
injectés pour le territoire
lors des six premiers mois de cette
année audi tout de suite je suis pas je
ne suis pas un observateur
hyper mois passés à la 7e non non je ne
les intéresse pas du tout mais ça j'ai
pas de détails et ou de saturer vous
dire globalement votre négociation
globale ya des choses que ça marche bien
et des choses vous ça marche moins bien
donc
donc comme comme partout mais je vous
dis je une globale alors je vais pas
satisfaisant non non ça peut vraiment
s'améliorer non pour vraiment
s'améliorer ont suivi on peut vraiment
s'améliorer je le fonctionnement pour
qu'une plus grande fluidité des choses
fluidité de l'action je trouve que ça
prend un peu trop de temps je trouve
qu'on peut aller plus vite on pourrait
aller plus vite beaucoup plus vite
notamment en organisant un peu mieux les
circuits l'information entre les
services donc mais c'est une grande
maison c'est pas mal mais peut mieux
faire
oui oui au niveau de l'organisation au
niveau de l'organisation
nous allons entamer la dernière séquence
de ce face à la première avec fred
michel tir au maire de saint-esprit est
aussi président de l'est républicain de
martinique
[Musique]
face à la première
justement fred michel tir où on termine
avec bientôt cette élection à la
présidence de l'est républicain
nouvelles élections
ce sera le premier tour est fixé au 10
décembre donc c'est très bientôt
on rappelle qu'il ya trois candidats en
lice laurent wauquiez j'ai oublié son
prénom manade caillan alors mal de
calories et florent soit la florence
portelli comment comment vous vivez
cette campagne électorale interne au
gros party les républicains et notamment
comment s'est déclinée en martinique est
ce que vous en parlait ce que ça fait
débat est ce que vous vous organiser
dans les instances du parti pour elle
est très calme cette campagne alors ce
matin à 10 heures nous avons organisé
une réunion justement avec tous les
militants pour présenter les différents
candidats parce que certains ne sont pas
connues nous avons trois candidats vous
l'avez dit mais le canon qui un breton
originaire du finistère qui à 37 ans qui
est conseiller départemental dans le
finistère qui pas très connue au niveau
national mais qui a équipé
voilà qui a milité aux côtés d'alain
juppé nous avons aussi une fille yunist
florence portelli 39 ans qui qui à
quimerc'h de taverny donc c'est une
ville quand même de 27 mille habitants
qui est conseiller régional d'île de
france et qui est proche de françois
fillion puisqu'elle a été porte parole
de françois fillon c'est quelqu'un qui a
une expérience politique
quand même assez ancienne puisque dès
l'âge de 24 ans elle était attachée
parlementaire
donc ça veut dire que depuis plus de 15
ans elle connaît les arcanes au niveau
national nous avons aussi laurent
wauquiez qui a 42 ans qui le président
de la région auvergne rhône-alpes qui a
été plusieurs fois ministre qui a occupé
des fonctions importantes au sein du
parti
ce qu'on constate c'est que ce sont eux
que l'on dit proche de nicolas sarkozy
qui est effectivement proche de nicolas
sarkozy qui était député avec novembre
et qui aujourd'hui à la tête de la
région la plus dynamique de france
si vous voulez en a trois candidats on
constate que ce sont trois candidats
quand même jeunes parce que le fait qu'
on est un prisonnier public jeune ça
quand même étalonner les choses comme ça
ça a donné le là on va dire est ce qui a
permis aussi peut-être renouvellement
des générations les jupes et les sarkozy
et fillon au sein du parti ont ont
estimé qu'il fallait aujourd'hui laissé
la main puisque il ya un président de 40
ans donc on va pas non plus allé prendre
des ministres de 70-75 anciens il faut
le dire donc que vous avez vous remarqué
que monsieur le président à mâcon s'est
entouré des gens peu de son de son âge
oui et ça a étalonné un peu les choses
aussi bien au parti socialiste un des
grands partis on pense à au
renouvellement avec déjà un peu de cette
génération et aux et public et on n'y
échappe pas avec des gens qui n'ont même
pas la quarantaine de voiliers et qui
ont quand même une expérience politique
voilà assez assez importante ils ont à
leur avantage effectivement une relative
jeunesse tout en ayant de l'expérience
politique vous le dit
en tout cas pour certains alors
évidemment je vous demandez vous est
neutre dans cette affaire en tant que
président de oui j'ai mon avis mais le
document que les élections auront lieu
le 10 voilà 7 mais c'est vrai que
maintenant qui est plus connu que les
autres donc ces voix qui paraît qu'un en
avantage en terme de notoriété ce qu'ils
disent ok on va la peine de faire des
l'action il est il et il est élu
d'avancé je dis qu'il faut attendre les
visiteurs parce qu'on n'est pas à l'abri
de
deux scores surprenants mais c'est vrai
que laurent wauquiez est plus connu que
mel de câlins et que florence portelli
cela va de soi et quand on est trop dur
d'accord ce sont les militants qui
votent
voilà voilà que mais il faut attendre le
résultat de l'élection chacun a ses
qualités à chacun a ses qualités et sous
l'échiquier ils sont pas positionnés
tout à fait de la même manière puisque
justement justement qu'est c'est une
grande famille qui laurent wauquiez il
essuie beaucoup beaucoup les critiques
de la part de des observateurs bien sûr
des journalistes etc mais aussi de ses
adversaires évidemment mais plus
largement quand on lit certains sondages
où l'image qu'il dégage
elle est assez clivante quand même et
même certains au sein du dd républicains
lui prête des velléités de se rapprocher
idéologiquement et peut-être même par un
accord du front national ce qui est
magique avec et effectivement les médias
et les lundis les bois n'en dénonce pas
les ouïes temps des grands duels mais
maël de calan lui-même critique laurent
wauquiez on n en attendait c'est parce
que la dérive
monsieur de la dérive des désirs et
africains vers l'extrême droite yeux car
oui ce n'est pas parce que ça c'est x
vous n'êtes pas chaque fois dire que
c'est les médias n'y entends déjà
quelque chose ou qu'ils inventent mais
attendez mais vous poser une question à
la cus pas les médias je vous dis
simplement que la rumeur vous avez vu et
des véhicules et les parts aussi par les
médias même parler watson on le voit
tous les jeux c'est pas qu'une rumeur le
matin michel céder saab sauvé moi ça se
base sur scéne additionner discours non
non non des indications qui sont donnés
par laurent wauquiez non dosé moi une
seule déclaration de monsieur laurent
wauquiez où il dit qu'il va se
rapprocher du front national trouvez moi
une seule une seule vous me citez je
vous écoute y'en a pas il y en a pas une
seule maudite tel jouet il a dit ça sous
tel média d'un tel journal montre il ya
encore parlé d'un homme charmant il n'en
a jamais mêlée parce que
comme ils entendent bien faire aux
géorgiens du comme certains électeurs
qui selon lui sont pas reçus vers le
front national sur les faire revenir
normale sur le plan des idées mais ça
veut dire qu'ils ont ce qu'on dit c'est
ce que c'est sur le plan des idées mais
se rapproche de données de cette
politique vise à ratisser très large
tournante sera content d'avoir des
électeurs de partout monsieur mâcon
qu'est ce qui fait une gratte east à
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême moi tu vois
quelques il vient de recruter dans son
gouvernement un ministre issu des rangs
du parti socialiste qui a voté contre ce
budget il ya deux semaines voyez donc
entre copains il a convaincu mais c'est
ça aussi la politique
yamasawa padilla peuvent danger latent
là est du point de vue idéologique pour
les républicains
aa savez quand vous êtes aux
responsabilités la question non non et
surtout vous craquerez publiques à amman
en dédicace républicain de l'avenir nous
le dira monsieur carouge
laissons attendons comme on dit wait and
see pas de procès d'intention ne faisons
pas de procès d'intention moi je vous
dis c'est pas forcément le candidat dont
je suis le plus prochain mais je dis pas
de procès d'intention j'ai bien étudié
les discours des bruits qui circulent
des uns et des autres moi j'ai entendu
le même bruit que vous sur laurent
wauquiez mais je vous dis j'ai vérifié
je n'ai pas trouvé une seule déclaration
ou monsieur l'on invoqué disait qu'il
voulait s'associer maintenant je sais
par expérience que quand on est aux
responsabilités on est obligé de
gouverner au centre ça c'est jusqu'où ça
se voit pour le président de la
république sait se voit partout se
voient pour pour les élus aussi au sein
des partis laurent wauquiez mais le cas
lance portelli quel que soit celui ou
celle qui sera élu au soir du 17
décembre il sera obligé de payer avec
tout le monde est de rassembler et
chacun l'a dit ils y ont tous dit nous
serons obligés de travailler tout le
monde parce que il y va de la survie
aussi de notre famille politique parce
que lui il faut un remake est en
fâcheuse posture que le phénomène des
socialistes de l'hexagone tous les
paysages politiques socialistes à
volants a explosé en plein vol
nous nous avons été touchés mais on a
quand même plus d'une centaine de
députés on a gardé le sénat en
maintenant notre que notre avance on axe
en l'accension d'ailleurs donc ça veut
dire qu'on est on reste quand même le le
premier parti d'opposition de toute la
france ce n'est pas rien c'est vrai
qu'on était fragilisé il appartiendra
nouveau président de rassembler tous les
militants et puis de reconquérir les
places que nous avons perdu tout
simplement et il a besoin est il ou elle
ou celui ou celle qui sera élue aura
besoin de tout le monde a besoin de la
force de tous les républicains et du
talent de tous les républicains et de
tous les militants également fait de
michel giraud pour pour terminer donc
premier tour le 10 décembre
le vote aura lieu aussi en martinique
vous vous organiser pour ça de manière
classique on viendra voter au siège non
sociologue électronique les gens qui ont
voté un curé les chez eux nous allons
encore installé quand même au siège un
ordinateur les militants pourront venir
donc je profite de votre aide pour
appeler numéro 6 ans 7 608 chez le
numéro de lignes mobiles 607 608 et vous
aurez toutes les modalités pour le vote
le 10 et le 17 décembre
d'accord mais qui se fera par véronique
vous pouvez voter de chez vous de vous
déplacer pour venir aussi sur plateau
technique
les résultats sont connus immédiatement
entendu merci fred michel thiry
président des républicains de l'est
républicain de martinique et maire de
saint-esprit d'avoir répondu à nos
questions dans le cadre de ce face à la
première qui était réalisé par cédric
berkeley merci pour votre attention
à bientôt
face à la première
[Musique]